all right
we are now live for the ask me anything
session
for may 2020 we've got some questions
already lined up
and i'm here on a cold may
more well not morning afternoon now here
in milwaukee wisconsin
i'm just looking out that way because
the city's over
that way so let's take the first
question from
spa bed hello doc sandler i hope
quarantine isn't going too bad
i wanted to ask whether you read
anything from david benny hart and about
your opinion of universal salvation
early so yeah i've read everett hart um
mostly
in terms of him writing things about
uh you know contemporary culture and
about
uh saint ansel in particular who unlike
most other orthodox he doesn't misread
uh and is actually you know fairly
sympathetic to the anselmi
project um he's he's not somebody who
i'm particularly
interested in um and the notion of
universal salvation
to me seems you know i think
a lot of people that are into it are
more motivated by wishful thinking
than by um you know rigorous
argumentation or
finding things in you know um
religious texts but and so it's kind of
a non-starter for me i i don't have much
interest in that
heart is is worth reading um he's
definitely somebody
who takes the continental tradition and
philosophy or traditions
seriously and so that that's kind of
good as well
all right i i can't um read arabic
uh so i'm not gonna try to pronounce the
name there dr sandler
uh the question is how will the world of
post-coronavirus
through human beings lifestyles
technology and fear of the unknown
uh be in the future so you know that's a
good question
i think a lot of people imagine that
we're just going to go
right back to normal and that's that's
what's motivating if any of you have
seen like the protests going on here
to reopen the economy and reopen this
and reopen that
those seem to be driven by people who
have a view that
everything was a-okay before and then
it's just the government
tyrannizing over us and using this as an
opportunity to power grab
and and quite frankly things weren't
good before this i mean
one of the reasons why we have such a
big
problem here in america you know that we
can we can really talk about the corona
response being handicapped by three main
factors here in america
one of which is the the fact that we
have a government that
is is just you know pretty corrupt and
uh not and very partisan and not
particularly useful and we could put
that aside
even if we didn't have trump in charge
let's say clinton had won we would still
be handicapped by two
really major factors one of which is
that we
have this antiquated uh federalist
structure which is not serving us very
well when it comes
to quite a few things and it's it's not
federalists when it comes to like
military but it is federalists when it
comes to things about public health
so our response has been very difficult
to coordinate
um you can see that like here in
wisconsin
um we do have a stay at home order but
you know it's up to the
the republicans decided to sue in the
wisconsin supreme court which is
dominated by republican appointees to
try to overturn it
and so you can't really get much of
anything done the other big problem is
we don't have a healthcare system we
have a patchwork of different systems
and you know most of them are driven by
by
profit things or by
rather dubious politics on both
republican and democrat sides so
you know the normal for us is that a lot
of people
are screwed when it comes to health care
and i don't think that we can
keep up that normal going forward
um so i think we're gonna you know it's
gonna depend from country to country to
country but
i think we're gonna see some serious
effects coming out of it
it's also gonna affect how we do
education you know the schools here we
we found out today that
university of wisconsin-milwaukee is
planning on doing face-to-face classes
in the fall and that's that's cool if
they can pull it off
um daughter is actually planning on
going to school there
but um you know my wife and i who are
both seasoned educators we've both been
in administration
we're both kind of problem solvers we're
like i don't think this is actually
going to work they're probably going to
revise that one of the other places i
teach milwaukee and since part design
they did the blood all right i already
decided fall classes are going to be
uh are not going to be face-to-face
they're going to be online
and that's that's the right decision but
places like university wisconsin
milwaukee
they need that student money because
they sunk a lot of money into dorms and
health
you know not healthy food plans and
stuff like that
marquette university further just a
little bit down the road over here
has spent even more of their money on
dorms and so they want to recoup that
money back
and i think we're going to see a lot of
students who are going to be like screw
it
i'm not i'm not coming back here i don't
know that it's safe um
and so there's a lot of annotation
that's that's required uh because this
is not the first of
the pandemics that we're going to have i
mean after we get through this
assuming that we don't have an even
larger second wave because of all
dummies who want to reopen everything
too early
and don't want to stay in quarantine and
wear masks and you know practice basic
hygiene and stuff like that
because of liberties you know um if we
after we have our second wave and more
deaths i think that you know we're gonna
we're gonna rethink how many things in
the future and so hopefully people will
be
a little bit more rational about that
all right let me see uh so kebabs 222
wants me to address the kamu question
could i explain kamu's logical
connection between the absurd and not
choosing
suicide i understood that you must have
both components role in person but i
think there's something missing so
um there isn't a logical uh connection
between the absurd and not choosing
suicide it's an
option um the absurd is a traumatic
relation
uh between the person the world and
by person we mean not just the
individual person but also their desires
their rationality
and the world that they live in and the
divorce between them
and then you once you become aware of
the absurd which you never do as
a totality you you always do in
particular ways
you have a choice do you want to
withdraw from it
in some way or another and suicide would
be one way of doing that physical
suicide
but also what kamu calls philosophical
suicide and that that's where
a lot of people get confused they say oh
come who's not an existentialist he
rejected it
he's targeting the theistic
existentialists when he does that
um and he talked specifically about
kierkegaard
lev shestoff and carly
ospers and if i he doesn't mention
gabriel marcel but he could have
mentioned marcel in there and so in
camus view
um and he realized you know that that
this is
is essentially a personal preference on
his part
if you want to be the kind of person who
values consistency and there's you know
you don't have to be
but he thinks that that you know he
advocates for doing that
then you shouldn't um just give in to
the absurd
and you shouldn't live in in what he
would view as sort of fantasies
uh where things somehow make sense you
shouldn't take the absurd and turn it
into
uh you know a form of god or you know a
way to justify a leap of faith you
should instead
go his path and and revolt
and that revolt in the myth of sisyphus
is against suicide and revolt in
his later the rebel is in terms of
violence
and murder so it's not it's not just
about
suicide it's about it's about other
things as well another another good
um thing for getting perspective on
camus is his four letters to a german
friend
written um during the nazi occupation
and
shortly afterwards where camus
is writing as somebody who does think
that you know absurdity is
is the human condition but we can still
talk about things like decency
we can stand up for that um and he
thinks that
the france of his time managed to hold
on to those values that the germans had
largely lost
all right anubis asks what do you think
about schopenhauer will you make a video
about him yeah eventually i'll make
videos
about about uh schopenhauer i rarely
make just
a video about anybody these days um
i actually i don't know if i still have
it down here but i had it
here for oh yeah here it is um so
for my ethics class i i was going to do
some stuff from on the basis of morality
about
schweppenhauer's his open house ethics
of compassion
and i've got the thumbnails for it i
just haven't gotten around to shooting
the videos and of course the semester
is practically over so there's no rush
anymore to shoot those videos but i'll
probably do it over the course of the
summer and
why not you know schopenhauer is an
interesting interesting guy
he has a lot of interesting things to
say
i you know i've mentioned this before i
actually had the opportunity to take
a graduate-level schopenhauer class with
wolfgang schermacher who is
at one time the president of the
international schopenhauer
society and really interesting guy i was
at european graduate school when i was
there as a visiting scholar uh one of
the perks was that they let me take one
class
and uh it was kind of funny i'll tell
you a little side story so
my my wife was there studying she that's
where she
you know did her doctoral residency and
all that
and she works at the at that time she
was at the culinary institute of america
now they're one of her clients she's
very connected in the food scene
and schermaker somehow got it stuck in
his head that i was a chef
and so he kept on calling he was
surprised that i was a chef
who had a phd in philosophy i'm not a
chef uh but
he'd got it in his head and so he kept
calling me the chef in class
and there's all these grad students most
of whom were you know 20 years younger
than me or
15 years younger than me and uh all of
them trying to like jockey for position
the way graduate students do and impress
the
the master and then he'd turn to me
every once in a while after
interpretation say
what do you think is that [ __ ] or
not what do you think chef
so he was quite quite absurd there as
well
all right enough about that let's let's
get another question
would i happen to know any books or
other sources that describe 19th or 20th
century intellectual history
or just the most important ideas and
thinkers in general of that time i'm not
a very good person to ask about
in you know like secondary sources or
introductory sources or stuff like that
because i spend very little time with
that and when i teach my classes i have
my students read primary texts and
i give them my own you know resources to
to work with
um i mean you know when i was in grad
school
uh frederick cobblestone's history of
philosophy which is you know quite
serviceable and often quite good was
kind of the standard
uh what was nice about cobblestone is he
included a lot of passages from the
people that he was talking about and he
was generally
not off target you know like if you read
william durant's history of philosophy
you're getting a lot more durant than
you're getting the history of philosophy
it's very popular
but um you know you got to be a little
wary of those things
and when you read these overarching
histories they often try to
summarize people and place them into
context that when you read the primary
text you're like
that was actually not quite correct um
so i don't have any good recommendations
as far as that goes um
john says i just bought aristotle's
metaphysics
and i've been wanting to read it for a
while any advice i'm not trained in
reading philosophy
well uh okay so i can tell you that one
is is not an introductory text you're
gonna
read it and be very frustrated at first
because you're gonna be like what the
hell is he talking about here what is
this
what does this mean and i don't think it
matters which translation you have
um you're gonna run into some some
problems
you know with any book of philosophy
you should well imagine that you're
going to have to read
and reread and re-read and with
aristotle's metaphysics it's going to be
even
more the case i would say
that is going to be
you know that's going to be uh uh
a tough one so
i actually wouldn't begin with the
metaphysics i would pre if you were
going to start with aristotle i would
actually start with
um maybe the nickel mccain ethics or
or something else you know um
the categories is um
yeah even the categories is not an
introductory work it's often
uh presented as if it's an introductory
work but
it's it's quite tough okay you know
there's no
there's no easy way into aerosol i do
have a video on like you know studying
aristotle
as a self-directed learner that might be
helpful for you
the other thing i'd say to remember is
that
so with aristotle this is particularly
important but this
this applies to a lot of other
philosophers as well you're reading him
in translation don't expect a one-to-one
correspondence between
english terms and greek terms
in um what you're reading
so don't make inferences based on what
you think the english term means
um because you might be going going
astray from
from what the text uh has all right
uh joust mike just want to say i
appreciate your videos have no pressing
question at the moment but since this is
an ama
i'll ask what have you been doing during
quarantine any netflix or novel
recommendations so um you know
i i went into quarantine along with my
wife before
quarantine officially started here
because she
had what we at that time thought was
influenza
and so you know i i've been staying here
i've been going out because until we had
to put our dog down i was taking her out
three times a day sometimes
more times a day and
since then i've been taking you know
three mile walks for exercise around
here
um and what else
you know finishing up the semester i
i was already teaching quite a few
classes and three of them were online
two of them had to go online so there
was that
and walking my my online newly online
students through things
even with the the classes that were
already online we lost some of the
students because they kind of fell
through the cracks even though we
tried to reach out and contact them
you know some had rough family
situations or
job situations going on and one of my
classes
is exclusively prison students in the
wisconsin department of corrections
and most of my students have been able
to complete their work for the semester
but
it's been very difficult to even get
information about what's going on in the
doc
so that's you know the academic stuff
obviously i've still been you know doing
my normal work of tutoring and
philosophical
counseling and the radio show and
um you know working with a variety of
organizations everything had to go
online um
i wasn't able to go to the gym anymore
so you know
i've been exercising at home i've got
some some dumbbells
and you know the stairs that you can see
right there um you know i can like do
dips
on those and a few other exercises
um and that's that's my stairmaster too
let's go up and down the stairs
um you know and then we we dealt with my
having to put our dog down or 14 year
old dog
over there in the corner you can see our
17 year old cat
munching away on on her stuff um
so she's you know she's been kind of a
thing
now as far as like netflix or reading
recommendations i haven't i i won't say
that i've done more
reading because i'm not yet finished
with the semester
but i've been i've been re-watching dark
matter that sci-fi series
on on netflix and i really enjoyed it
it's
it's really too bad that they decided to
end the series after three uh seasons
because it was really quite good
now that i'm i'm watching it first
season couple you know
weak spots but it really held up we've
also been watching this this british
cop show called new tricks and it's
it's quite good too it was done in the i
think it started in the late 90s
and continued through or maybe it
started in the early 2000s and continued
through
for about you know 13 or 14 seasons
and it's very well written a lot of fun
um
cool characters cool actors doing it
um what else nothing else really comes
to mind we've been
saving westworld until we can watch like
the whole series
i've been looking forward to that um
haven't watched the new rick and morty's
yet because i want to see what my kids
want to do if they want to
wait and watch them together if we
possibly have
a nice summer vacation together but
we'll see what happens with that
so all right fruiting body reviews isn't
causal determinism kind of a weak
argument against free will because it's
inherently fallacious
well it's not an argument against free
will it's a position
namely that everything is determined and
you know strict determinism would say
everything is determined even if we
think that we're
behaving freely that's just not the case
and so it's better to say it would rule
out free will
although free will is a very slippery
term it means a lot of different things
to a lot of different people
and you know there are compatibilist
positions that
um you know say that there there's
there's a causal nexus and determinism
but it's possible for us
as agents within that to introduce some
some freedom sometimes even increase the
freedom within it
i'm attracted to positions like that
myself
um i i i think you can say that some
positions that are deterministic
are pretty crude and generally rely on
one fallacy or another but
i don't think that you can just dismiss
causal determinism as such
by saying that it's it's fallacious um
so yeah all right change my mind do i
agree with hume that reason is a slave
to the passions
no i i think and i don't think that even
hume actually believes that if you read
the rest of his work
um including that very chapter of the
treaties in which he says that
um that's typical hume you know same
thing with
hume's fork doesn't actually hold up you
know
um but you know he was great at at
rhetoric
and sometimes reason is a slave to the
passions and and you know that's that's
often the case for people who are poorly
developed morally speaking
um but it doesn't always have to be so
there and even in people who are
striving towards virtue
part of the challenge is realizing
where you where your your reasoning
processes are
in fact just being subordinated to
desire or passion
and why that can be a bad thing now we
don't want to
we don't want to say that that we should
you just abandon emotion or passion or
desire or affectivity altogether
as a matter of fact when you look at
classic virtue ethics
the goal is generally to have um
the affective and rational sides of our
self well integrated with each other
and emotion can often reveal things to
us that we
need to take into account in our
practical reasoning
all right anubis have i ever heard of
emil sharon
yep i heard of him uh years and years
ago and read a bit of him and
someday might read some more uh
per obazione any tips for someone who
wants to study heidegger with no
previous information on him
yeah don't start with being in time
uh that's that's that's jumping in like
jumping into the deep end of the pool um
i would like look at some essays
by him and even that's going to be tough
um i mean my favorite essay to start
to start beginners out on and i do this
with undergraduates who are not
philosophy majors
is what is metaphysics sorry about that
that's why i put together those videos
and then created those podcast episodes
on what is metaphysics the core concept
ones and the sadler's lectures ones
because i think that's
that's one of the best avenues to get
into heidegger's stuff you're getting a
little bit of some of the ideas and
seeing how they're connected together
and you're also you know you might say
you're getting
acclimated to heidegger's prose and the
way that he does things
um could heidegger have been more clear
probably you know um
but he does have his his style
and so it's good to learn what that
style is like
um before you start getting into larger
works so all right tr
oh there's a really interesting question
what sort of books did you read before
you got into philosophy
so got into philosophy could mean a
couple different things i mean it could
mean like when i
formally began studying philosophy
which i suppose you would say is when i
went to college in 1990
although i had two classes that i would
count as philosophy classes
in high school one of them was
officially
intro to philosophy and it sucked it was
awful we used martin marvin gardner's
uh wise of a philosophical scrivener
which
is not a terrible book but it's not a
great book it's very dry and dull
and the teacher was just not a very good
teacher either
uh and that almost turned me off on
philosophy and then i had i've talked
about this in a video
about the teachers who've been
influential in my life
i had mr lorenzo for sacraments and he
turned the sacraments class
this might be why he wasn't asked to
come back
into a philosophy class where we studied
plato and aristotle and
augustine and then also talked about
jung and freud
and that was in high school but and i
also like got a few books here and there
you know my the first philosophy book i
tried to read i won't say i actually
read it
was uh the mythic synthesis and i found
that in my uncle's
um bedroom uh he had lots of books piled
up
and i was like hey can i have this and
he's like yeah sure whatever kid
and so i tried to make my way through
and i probably only understood a tenth
of what i was reading but i thought it
was pretty cool stuff
so i mean you can say that i got into
philosophy
certainly in my teenage years right um
read some when i was in the army as well
now what was i reading before i was
reading philosophy
um that's a real that's the really
interesting thing
i was reading um a good bit of history
and part of that was promoted by the
fact that my father
who unfortunately died when i was 11
he was really into history and he had a
great you know sort of uh shelf
of of uh historical works
um and i would get things from the
waukesha library
i'm pointing that way because it's you
know west of here
that's west and um
you know i was into there were certain
things i was really into like i was into
you know the story of the mongols and
this this vast empire that they had
um you know ancient
rome and greece and i was into military
history quite a bit
and um i was also like my dad had little
hearts book on strategy
on the wall so by the time i was like
you know 11 i was learning about the
indirect approach and
things like that and my parents also had
quite a few psychology books on the wall
as well and so i read some of that but
what i really loved the most
was fantasy and science fiction
and some horror you know the whole realm
of what we would call speculative
fiction these days i was reading a lot
of that
as as a kid by the time that i was
you know in in uh middle school i'd read
the lord of the rings and the hobbit
and a lot of ursula k le guin and i was
reading
you know ben bolva and asimov
and um well even
who i discovered in my uncles my great
uncle's library
um and i you know i was fortunate that i
i didn't come from a particularly
literate family and i certainly didn't
come from an academic
or professional family most of the
people in my family were essentially
blue collar
but they were you know some of them were
readers
my uncle eubert was a great example
but also my uncle amy who i got the
mythocyphesis from
um and so there was this promotion of
of reading and there weren't a lot of
restrictions there
it wasn't like oh you can't read that
book because that's dirty or anything
like that
and there also wasn't oh don't read that
sort of stuff because that's going to
rot your mind
elitist sort of things either and so
you know um i was kind of fortunate with
that and i retained that interest in
speculative fiction throughout my my
life
um all right uh
muhammad tala what's my view about
prayer personal congregational whatever
um you know i think that a lot of people
pray for kind of cockamamie things you
know like
the song about lord won't you get me a
mercedes benz and i
i think a lot of prayer is done in kind
of showy ways
um you know you see these people who are
praying over somebody else but you know
the abuse of something doesn't negate
the proper use of it
i think that uh there's a lot of
different ways to access the divine and
prayer
properly done can be one of them um
i guess the challenge with it is like
figuring out how to
how to do it in ways that are effective
for oneself right
um anubis what would you recommend to a
student who wants to participate at
international philosophy olympia i don't
know that's the first i've ever heard of
that that sounds like an interesting
thing but i don't know much about it i
guess
you could like you know is is it like a
contest where you prepare
for for uh
you know struggling with philosophy or
something like that i don't i don't
really know
there's bruce hey bruce long time
correspondent
of mine i'm glad to see you here
and uh looking forward to seeing you
perhaps later on today in the philosophy
chat for
for you know uh patreon supporters
uh i sent you the link so
one of the cool things i'll mention this
um about
doing the work that i do is that i've
formed these
like years old connections with a
variety of people who i
interact with fairly frequently all
around the world
you know and people who i would never
have gotten to meet
or know were we not in this this world
of the
the internet right so kind of a kind of
a cool thing
all right it's scrolled down a little
bit let me see what we've got here
um vince asks about the kyoto school
um people have recommended them to me
they sound quite interesting
i haven't read stuff by them so i need
to uh
uh get into that eventually but i don't
know when i'm gonna have the
time to do it uh the great race of yif
the little cthulhu reference there uh
says to what extent do you believe in
the existence of natural rights if at
all
i mean i think that we do have some
things that are natural rights i think a
lot of the people who talk about natural
rights today are full of crap and using
them basically just to like
browbeat other people into um
you know not not looking out for the
common good i mean
if there are natural rights they are
going to be within a framework
of the common good uh i think and so
quite often there will be things that
trump natural rights i think a lot of
people treat natural rights as if
they're like a
uh we've decided the thing right here
and you know can't go any further um
so i tend to be a little bit dubious
about the rights talk i always want to
know what they're supposed to be
grounded on and if you just say oh
just nature that's not that's not good
enough for me i need to see something
more and it better be more than just
you know well the constitution or the
declaration as well
all right uh maxwell could you tell us a
bit of a personal history of your belief
in god were you ever an atheist how so
did you grow to believe
that's an interesting question was i
ever really an atheist
um i mean there's a lot of ways to be an
atheist
you can be an atheist by like making a
declaration of your atheist allegiance
and
being a crusader and you know just as
just as uh committed as any
any sort of fanatic uh on the religious
side and i've seen quite a few people
like that and
you know sort of on the other end of the
spectrum you could be what you call a
practical atheist and i think a lot of
religious
people are actually practical atheists
because whatever religion they espouse
doesn't make a damn bit of difference in
their life
you know they they'll they'll like say
yeah i'm a catholic i was baptized
and you'd be like well okay so what do
you do
oh i don't really you know maybe
christmas and easter
okay well you may as well be an atheist
then and then there's like the people
who like go to church
you know every day i'm there at daily
mass but
you know you look at them and you're
like you're a complete bastard
clearly whatever you know you you're
hoping to get out of it hasn't made any
effect on you
you're just as selfish and you know uh
bigoted as as anybody else around you
and
you know if you if you go to church
every day and you don't recognize
yourself
in the pharisee well you might have a
little problem there
um you know i always ask christians how
are you doing with the sermon on the
mount which is
quite difficult to live up to so it's
hard to say
i mean we can talk about atheists in a
lot of ways
i'll put it to you like this so i'll
give you the history
i grew up as a kid um
within a family that actually had two
priests
you know two of my great uncles were
priests and there was
always a current of um
you know religious attendance and
talking about things
my dad was not particularly
uh devout and i think he probably was
was an
atheist but he would go every once in a
while my mom
in part because one of my grandmother's
dying wishes was that we'd go to mass
every sunday
you know we we had to and we'd always we
try all sorts of dodges can we go to
just watch mass for shut-ins
you know because we wanted to watch like
cartoons in the morning they had
cartoons on sunday morning
and um you know i'd go and i'd
participate in the rituals but
i didn't really have any much
understanding of what was going on
because catechesis was terrible in the
1970s um
as a reaction against the very hardcore
baltimore catechism
catechesis of you know this is all the
stuff you need to know
it was more loosey-goosey like well how
do you feel about this and
you know god is love so just be nice to
each other
for me i was like well this is kind of
this doesn't mean anything you know
um and at the same time i was attracted
to the idea of there being some sort of
transcendent
reality and it being you know in some
way personal
and i wanted to know more about that but
i never really ran
into anybody who could could adequately
explain that
and you know this continued on i went to
middle school and then i went to a
catholic high school
and in the catholic high school i left
the catholic church
again because nobody could give me any
decent answers for anything and it
seemed much more about
um fitting in and and you know
controlling people and i i really just
wasn't exposed at all to what we could
call the catholic intellectual tradition
which includes people who i work on and
teach like you know
anselm of canterbury or thomas aquinas
or maurice blondel
and that just wasn't you know on the
radar
of of people at that time and i had a
very strong interest in world religions
that
you know began i would say you know in
my middle school years
i began you know reading and whatever i
could find
i mean back then it wasn't like today
where you can easily find resources
everywhere you had to go to the library
and see what they had
you know you're kind of stuck with
whatever whatever you get your hands
on um and so that you know things went
on that way for
quite a long time i would say that you
know practically speaking i was an
atheist through my army years and
into college and you know i remember
actually i was i was
i never got confirmed which is an
important ritual within
um you know all of the the churches uh
from
catholicism on on east right
all the apostolic churches and it's also
kind of important for lutherans and
anglicans as well and um
i didn't get confirmed because i was
like well i'm not gonna buy into this
stuff and say that i agree with it when
i don't agree with it
uh and all my friends are doing it just
so they can get presents from their mom
mom and dad and you know not get in
trouble with them
so you know i didn't i ended up getting
confirmed when i was around 28 but it
was because i
came back and it was through you know
essentially seeing the catholic
intellectual tradition
thinking about what you know how was
somebody like anselm
or blondel produced by this matrix and
then
finding something more authentic and
genuine and
at this point in time i can't say that
i'm particularly devout
you know i don't i don't go to to mass
very often
um and you know i've got some serious
beefs with the
way the church has been run for a very
long time
you know it's like the bishops you think
they can't disappoint you
any more than they already have and they
always surprise you that way
um so i don't know what's going to go on
i mean i i respect certain orders like
you know i like the benedictines quite a
bit
um but the totality of
the hierarchy i'm not real fond of and
there's a lot more that could be said
about that um
but i think that probably suffices for
now so
all right lenny penny when i look at
nietzsche's genealogy of morals
post-modern theory and marxism
i can't see any fundamental differences
it both sounds like oppressor versus a
press same with post-modernism what's
the difference
well there's lots of differences i think
you need to re-read um
you know it's it's if you think that
it's just a presser versus oppressed and
the modes of oppression don't matter
or um that nietzsche is is that
simplistic or marcus is that simplistic
or post-modernism
post-modernism is that simplistic i
think you probably approached it with
that in mind
and so you probably need to spend more
time
i would actually get my hands on you
know
leotards the post-modern condition if
you want to talk about post-modernism
read your way through that
and then get jameson's post-modernism
the cultural logic of late capitalism
and you'll see that there's a lot of
diversity within
what's called the post-modern i mean
there are some interesting connections
between
marx and nietzsche on this axis of not
just oppression but exploitation
domination replication of social
uh you know social functions
um so you know it's not like you're
totally off base on that but
it's it's not just that all right uh
stephen warren do you have a song that
you find philosophically significant
that really inspires you
yeah um
and it's a mega death sign you know it
kind of expresses
something at the core of my attitude
about politics
and society uh and it's you know
peace cells right and it's because of
that line
if there's a new way i'll be the first
in line but it better work this time
i have very limited um
tolerance for the same old
corrupt [ __ ] going on whether it's
coming from the right or the left or
from from the always you know
gutless center um the
let's let's just keep doing things the
same way but like change the terminology
or stuff like that
and i you know i mean the song itself is
is
the rest of it's kind of funny you know
um
you can listen to it on your own but
that refrain is
is something that has expressed the way
i feel about things for a very very long
time
if there is a new way i'll be the first
in line i am ready to commit to
social reform because i'm a virtue
ethicist i care about the common good i
want to see things
you know done well instead of the
usually
mediocre ways that we do things but it
better work this time
no more bullshitting around actually
doing it the right way
um so that's that's one song that
expresses a lot for me
you know um all right
marcos asks are you gonna lecture at
marquette next semester
i may be accepted to their masters in
applied philosophy program
i don't know it always depends they
they're usually pretty slow in
getting getting organized like you know
at carthage i already have classes
lined up for a year in advance at
milwaukee institute of art and design
it's usually about six months to eight
months in advance
marquette it could be the week before
classes begin
when they call me up and they're like we
really need somebody to teach this this
class can you take it over
and i'll be like yeah i guess so i mean
it'd be nice to have some advanced
warning
so you know um who knows
and we don't even know if marquette's
gonna have face-to-face classes next
next term or not
um now if i was teaching you
you wouldn't have me teaching your
classes because they they have me
teaching service classes like
what used to be philosophy of human
nature and ethics has been combined into
foundations of philosophy that's the
main thing that i teach occasionally i
teach business ethics for them
um but that's that's not a graduate
level course so you wouldn't have me
teaching any of those courses you know
if i if i am teaching for them they give
me an
office and you'd see me there on campus
um
and you know if you are there i
encourage you to come in and say hello
but
that's you know that's about that and
and if you are
in the milwaukee area you should
probably connect up with me anyway
because
we do the milwaukee store fellowship and
milwaukee sofia
and all sorts of other philosophy
related events that you might want to
get in on
um so you know it's a good idea
all right uh let's see what else we've
got here
mj park i started to read more
philosophy
books but i like a place where to
discuss what i learned
read with someone else any
recommendations
yeah okay so that's a good question
there are lots and lots of
online communities that you can find
some of which are
you know not very good um and and when i
say not very good it could be
like it's all people who are just total
beginners and they're like
what what to read stoicism you know uh
or it could be a lot of people who like
just like to argue with each other and i
i know some people like that i don't
find that particularly
uh a good use of time in terms of
studying but there's also
plenty of good you know forums out there
and
you know right now this is something you
might want to check out so there's a lot
of meetups all over the world right
through meetup.com
and because of
coronavirus they've all basically gone
online
so like just last week i i you know i
posted a video
from the 52 great ideas meetup which
meets in new york they asked me to come
in for their stoic
saturdays and give a presentation and
then talk about stuff right
with it with their their membership and
after the presentation
they actually break up into small groups
and talk now there's nothing that
prevents
you from going online and joining that
meetup so i think that would be a a good
thing for you to
check out um
all right uh godfrey keller why is the
hegelian term geist often translated
into english's spirit
isn't the english word spirit referring
to the supernatural realm
um no it refers to all sorts of things
and it's same in french too you know
uh it's it's translated as esprit which
can mean
spirit mind and french it has an even
wider range because it can mean wit
um you know spirit is just fine for for
a translation of geist
because spirit isn't just like you know
a ghost or
spook or something along those lines you
know you talk about the spirit
of the law the spirit of the times
it's a wider-ranging term i i prefer
spirit
sounds better phenomenology is spirit
then phenomenology of mind
mind has kind of a restrictive uh sense
in
english all right uh
rt whitby we all know that you really
like aleister mcintyre's book after
virtue
but what parts of the book do you
disagree with the most and why i mean
it'd be better to say
that i really like aleister mcintyre's
work
after virtue is just one of many works
that he
wrote that are that are very good after
virtue is part of a
four book series which is followed by
a book that's even better than after
virtue whose justice which rationality
and then three rival versions of moral
inquiry
and then finally dependent rational
animals so you've got kind of a
hole there but you know mcintyre wrote
some great stuff
before that like against the self-images
of the day when he was
he's still sort of identifying as a
marxist
his book on the unconscious is great his
history of uh
moral philosophy is is quite good as
well
um
i mean when it comes to after virtue
i've i've already
you know i've signaled this in a couple
different places i've
i actually did a presentation on this
saying that
mcintyre not just an after virtue but
also the rest of his work
um his treatment of the medievals
is way to acquire his way to thomas
augustine centered
and it doesn't take enough account of um
other thinkers like anselm who were very
involved
in the gregorian reforms that he talks
about in his work
so you know there's there's quite a few
places where you can say his story is
just not
um there's two big holes in his story
stoicism is another great example
a long wrote a now classic piece
um years and years ago saying mcintyre
not only misreads the stoics as
proto-conscience
he also misses out on the fact that the
the modern stoic community uh
is doing the same thing as mcintyre is
talking about a sort of neo-aristotelian
community doing
and that these are two different strains
that could be
supporting each other so you know kind
of
but but mcintyre is cool with that he
also got really railed by the
kierkegaard scholars
they had as a matter of fact they put
together a whole book
of people laying into mcintyre
uh you know from the i think the
international kierkegaardian society
they did like a panel on
on him or the conference on his
treatment of kierkegaard
and mcintyre is cool with that he's like
yeah i didn't pretend that i
i knew everything and covered everybody
you know
you want to like uh say that you know
this group or this group or this group
has more resources than i thought
that's wonderful uh make the argument
i'm glad to see it you know
maybe virtue ethics of the sort that i'm
looking up can can
you know bring this in so all right
um anubis
uh asks is philosophy compatible with
psychology nature
is an adjective for philosophers which
psychology i mean
and which philosophy these are these are
highly ambiguous terms
and you know i would say the answer is
yes of course they are
um mj park any arabic philosopher you
recommend
i don't i don't work on arabic
philosophers so
i i wouldn't know who to recommend um
[Music]
muhammad asks aren't countries like
south korea taiwan and hong kong and
their systems social ethics and
government
proven to be better during the pandemic
compared to other prominent developed
countries
i don't know that it says anything about
their their social ethics i mean
you really think that hong kong is
exhibiting great social ethics on the
part of the the government
you know before coronavirus we were
having we're having
months and months and months of
demonstrations and
you know uh government forces attacking
the
the demonstrators so i i'd be a little
bit
leery about generalizing too much i will
say that
having the capacity to get you know
people to
um take the virus seriously and to
respond and not be selfish and talk
about their liberties all the time
is certainly an advantage for them i can
say that
all right uh renew do you think is a
global society will ever end war
clean up the planet get along and go
explore space together
within the next 50 to 100 years okay so
that's the crux
right here right do i think it's a
global society we'll do that in 50 years
50 to 100 years i mean i can be hopeful
but i don't think we will
i think we're still going to be
dominated by by
power blocks and i'll put it to you this
way
if we don't get our [ __ ] together uh
pretty soon then we're screwed as a
species
and so you know things look pretty bad
in the united states in part because
we've got so many citizens who are
so obsessed with their own little things
uh
and you know we have a i mean the the
fact that trump
has so many followers still uh given how
many
lies he's told and you know how
clearly bad many of the decisions he's
made are
shows that there's there's a lot of
people out there and i won't say that
they're just
that they're stupid but they're
certainly blinded
there's something really fundamentally
wrong and that's you know a large part
of the
the contemporary right these days in
america and you can't really do much of
anything
people who haven't abandoned him by now
um
they never will and um you know there's
plenty of people on the left that could
be
targeted as well and as i mentioned
there's the feckless center
the people who just want to like get by
and have their stuff or
you know play both sides and all that so
i don't think america is going to be a
leader
in solving these problems as a matter of
fact for the rest of the world it might
actually be a good thing if america goes
into decline
the trouble is do we want the chinese to
be the ones running the show it's not
gonna be the russians because they're
they're screwed as well um and
and we're not seeing any other great
global rivals rising i mean india is
there
uh but under the bjp party they're sort
of moving backwards in time
although bjp is slowly losing control
over the states
so i don't know um i'm not super
optimistic about our capacity to deal
with
global climate change pandemics um
you know human rights issues uh
immigration
these these massive things that we have
to worry about shifting away from fossil
fuels before we burn them all up
um these are all a lot of well and
toxins too
all right um kelly andreas rodriguez
rodriguez could i please comment about
the wrong application of preconceptions
in the pandemic so preconceptions uh
prolapse
is is a idea that you find in stoic
philosophy
and in epicurean philosophy and in stoic
philosophy the
prolapses are these general conceptions
that people have of like say the good
and the bad or what's in our control and
what's not in our control
and as epictetus describes it part of
what we have to do
is learn how to apply these properly and
so you could think of as
like refining these concepts an
epictetus says that these general
conceptions
as such do not conflict with each other
but they do
for like most people in the way that
they
they um they use it
um i i guess you could say that
that what would apply in terms of the
pandemic a lot of
moral concepts right are preconceptions
the advantageous and the disadvantageous
um people are often getting these wrong
and you know a lot of it is because
they're their reasoning processes
rather impoverished shallow they're not
using enough concepts so like you know
think about the quarantine thing
and opening the economy anybody who's
talking about
reopening the economy is full of crap
because the economy's been
open and still happening you know
we have shoppers come and bring stuff
you know i i can walk around here and
point to restaurants that are open
for curbside services you know uh
there's all sorts of things that are
still
going on so the idea that like there
would be like this
economy maybe with a capital e
that you know has been closed and now
needs to be open that's a screwed up
preconception that a person has
um and and quarantine is often being
presented as if it's like these
you know jack-booted people who are like
keeping us in and if you go outside of
your house you'll be penalized or
something like that
that isn't the experience of most people
um
as a matter of fact we might we might
not even really talk
successfully about quarantine stay at
home is not the same thing as quarantine
so you know there's all sorts of other
applications we might be able to
make of of that all right
uh mr dharam pagi why is academic
philosophy so detached from real human
problems
analytic philosophers and philosophers
of language i think you can include most
continental philosophers in there as
well
and i don't know that philosophy of
language is particularly susceptible to
that uh
you know any more than say philosophy of
mind or
you know even a lot of ethics is pretty
abstract
um i think part of it has to do with the
fact that most
academics are kind of one horse ponies
one trick ponies rather they they don't
you know this is a problem with with
philosophy right if you want to be a
really good philosopher
you really need to read widely and you
need to have thought about a lot of
things
and you don't necessarily have to have
like a system of the whole or anything
but you you'd better be able to wander
around in a lot of philosophical
neighborhoods
i just don't see any way to be any good
at philosophy
in a real broad sense without doing that
and most people aren't comfortable with
that they
they specialize in their little area and
that's that's that and they've been
allowed to do that for a long time
um so that's one issue you know the
rewarding of over specialization
and then i think you know a lot of um
i don't think this is just a
philosophical thing and i don't think
it's just a humanities thing stem people
are horrible at communicating
their ideas to most young people are
terrible at communicating their ideas to
other people and even the ones who are
like
master communicators often find ways to
to alienate people and look at neil
degrasse tyson
um people hold him up as if he's like
you know he's he's got great degrees and
he's done some interesting stuff but
man does he say some dumb stuff in a
very broad sense every once in a while
about
for example philosophy or human life
right um there's something about being
an intellectual
that disconnects one from the concerns
of ordinary people in many cases
and that's that's a real problem um
those of us who didn't grow up you know
surrounded by intellectuals are probably
at an advantage
those of us who've taught a lot of
service classes
uh who didn't get to just you know
specialize in
some area but had to make the case for
what we wanted to teach
to undergraduates who are not majors
were probably at a dis
at an advantage in being able to to
communicate and think about
real human problems all right uh
uh i'm going to skip over anubis because
i've already answered
some anubis's um john smith
what are your thoughts on practicing
writing skills if you're self-studying
philosophy
having trouble coming up with topics and
knowing if i do a good job so two
different issues
right trouble coming up with topics
i think there's there's probably a lot
of prompts out there
that you could find quite easily
just type in you know google and see
like writing prompts
plato writing prompts kant things like
that
now telling if you're doing a good job
that's where you probably do need to
have somebody else
looking at it i mean you can tell to
some degree whether you're doing a good
job
because you're not you know uh just a
robot
or or you know somebody who
can't have some reflexive
application of your ideas but it really
does help to have other eyes
on what you're looking at so i would say
you want to try to find other people who
are engaged in self-directed study and
again
i mentioned earlier there's all these
online groups
and meetups now is a really great time
to start forming
long-term friendships you know um
all right anthony fikry thoughts on
maurice blondell's letter on apologetics
um i think it's great you know i i think
blondel is a very
underrated thinker um and the letter on
apologetics is
you know it's written in a language of
its time
but you can say that about so many
others as well i mean think about
when we have to explain in rene
descartes uh meditations that objective
reality means something different
in in you know pre-modern and early
modern stuff than it does in late modern
stuff
um and and blondel was a really
brilliant thinker he identified some of
the major problems of his time
i find his his work uh you know very
very interesting
um all right uh storm slayer my opinion
on nick land
haven't read them so i don't really have
much of an opinion people are always
asking me about him i've said so many
times if somebody wants to send me a
print copy of feng numa
i'll read it but um until then
i have an opinion you know
okay stewarding company reading hegel's
phenomenology of the spirit especially
the section on consciousness and
observing reason i noticed a lot of
similarities between hegel and the
tractatus
how indebted is ludvig not at all
there's zero connection between the
tractatus and hegel as far as i can tell
and i don't see any similarities quite
frankly as a matter of fact
what what wittgenstein is proposing is
so static
compared to what hegel is outlining
there i
i don't see any any connection um
dale growlski what are my thoughts on
the buddhist concept of no self why is
this less prevalent in western thought
well it's you know the buddhist concept
of no self
is itself quite complicated and it's
saying that there's no
underlying atman you know it's not
saying that we don't have a phenomenal
self
which is what a lot of you know western
buddhists often
take it to mean and little you know
lesser known thing too there were also
there were buddhists who actually did
contest that they were called
um in the western literature on them
they're called personalists because they
thought there was an enduring self
but they were the minority and they
ended up losing the
the argument you often do see something
like a self
rearing its head when you look in in
buddhist
[Music]
schools as they develop over time why is
this less prevalent in western thought
i mean it's less prevalent in
everybody's thought most cultures think
that there is some enduring self
as far as we can tell
and buddhism would be the outlier in
that case
so all right um
[Music]
let's see here
ish to rocky my position in political
philosophy as in do i have any positions
in the field not not quite sure what's
being asked there
um i mean if you're asking about
um like political philosophy proper
i mean i i've said this before i i find
it very difficult to identify with
movements and things like that because
i'm ultimately a virtue ethicist
so you know i think that aristotle is
right
that there are often conflicting claims
and that
you know in addition to the claims of
the many
and the rich we also have the claims of
whatever group this is the actually
virtuous
and that they're the ones who tend to
hold society together
against the forces of the many and the
rich trying to you know get their own
stuff
and uh they're also like aristotle says
the least likely to engage in
faction or stasis um
i think that very few societies tend to
promote virtue well
um and i think that we have to use that
as a
lens so you know in the past i've been
much more critical of the left than i
than i was of the right at that time and
now i'm much more critical of the right
than i
that i am of the left um but both of you
know sort of like a pox on both houses
um and
you know i guess so you could say that
there's a certain pragmatism entailed by
a commitment to virtue ethics but being
a virtue ethicist means that you're
never going to have a comfortable place
to be in
um and you also have to be brutally
realistic about
the community that you live within
all right uh matthew curran in your
experience
what is the most important part of one's
philosophy graduate school application
i don't know i mean i i applied to
graduate school a long time ago
nobody told me how to do it as a matter
of fact my
writing sample probably would have got
me
not accepted at where i ultimately went
southern illinois university
had it not been for the fact that i
actually maxed one section of the gre
the analytics section um
and so i had such high test scores that
they they were into that
um it really depends on the place there
is
you know most of these application
processes are essentially a black box
you can do what they tell you to do if
you've got anybody who's got an
in maybe their opinion is helpful maybe
not depending on how well they
understand their department
so you know you don't know
all right uh leto the bee
been watching your older videos and saw
that recently you decided to work on
your overall physical health hopefully
you're still keeping up on it because
your progress is apparent
yeah i mean it's it's it's important and
uh i want to live
for quite a while so my you know i can
enjoy life with my
my wife and my kids and get a lot of
work that i want to get done
done um and uh
you know the biggest problem with me in
addition to time
because my time is always very in high
demand
and i never have enough of it was that
you know i used to be
i used to be really into physical
fitness
i'd work out about three hours a day
most days
and then i suddenly got bored with it
you know and
um it made it hard to get back into it
so when i when i actually have something
that works well for me like going to the
gym
that we have here which now is closed of
course
um i can do that or taking taking long
walks is also something
when i take a walk you know i was in the
army so i walk at like marching speed
you know 120 steps per minute whether i
like to or not
it's kind of ingrained in my head um i
get a good cardio workout in
um but it's it's always difficult to
make sure that i find the time what i
ended up having to do
was schedule appointments for myself to
work out
treat it like i was working with a
client so
all right um
let's see here jeff sullivan is there a
politician or political figure from
history you particularly like or look up
to that's interesting you'd ask that
um
somebody who i want to do more more work
on
yeah and and i may be mixing his name up
i often
twist his name around is the sixth
governor of our state of wisconsin
uh alexander randall
who was a republican back when
republicans were the anti-slavery party
and very much for
human rights um
he actually has a little known fact
about him he actually threatened to have
wisconsin secede from the union
if lincoln wasn't elected and
he didn't have to ultimately because you
know
lincoln was elected when he was here
wisconsin contributed
more than our fair share of troops to
fight against the
southern rebels and the civil war
and you know i think
i think that that um
the notion that slavery is the original
sin of the americas
along with the the you know oppression
and extermination and exploitation of
the native americans
uh i think that's that's quite true by
the way
i'm not the only person who thought that
alexis de tocqueville if you ever read
his democracy in america
he has a lot of good things to say about
america and then he's got a chapter
where he's like
the black and the red races and the way
americans have treated them
is their you know worst aspect of
america um and you know maybe it's gonna
undo them um so you know this area
the wisconsin was the most
uh pro-union anti-slavery
anti-confederate state in the nation i
would say
and um i agree with that sentiment i
i you know i think that randall was
in his own way kind of a hero and he had
to fight against forces who
who were against that that sort of
uh radicalism in his time so
you know that's that's a prime example
by the way
i'll say another thing too i think that
anybody who has a confederate flag here
in wisconsin i think
we ought to like honor our heritage by
saying anybody who's got a confederate
flag
they get punished for it the flag gets
burnt they get
you know fined put in jail something
i think that would be perfectly fitting
if people want to talk about heritage
and honoring it let's do it for the
north too
you know um my my great grandfather
on my my adoptive mother's side he
brought the family to the states
ultimately by fighting in the civil war
against the rebels
so something i feel particularly strong
about
uh quentin pascal what's a good approach
to tackling the neoplatonus they had to
go at platitus but struggled a bit
don't start with platinus that would be
one way of
i'm starting saying it right um
there there are other uh neoplatons who
are a bit
easier to to read than platinus is
platinus has got this very
big systematic thing going on and some
of these are people who are connected
with with platinus
um so i would i would take a look at
them and i would also read middle
middle platonist works before you jump
into neoplateness works
i particularly recommend plutarch you
know
usually we think about plutarch for his
biographies but plutarch also
wrote a lot of middle platonist
philosophy and that's that's a helpful
bridge um simplicius is somebody who's
good to look at
proclass uh albinus is somebody who
writes some some fairly short and
accessible treatys um
but you know the other thing to keep in
mind too is
when you're reading neoplatonists um
you're going to be reading some
some pretty weird stuff from the
contemporary perspective
and you got to kind of like it's almost
like
and i think you can say this with other
philosophies as well like reading kant
for example
you've got to like suspend disbelief a
bit
and don't worry so much about all you
know all that and just sort of like try
to get imaginatively
into the world that that they're
depicting
and then after you've got a good handle
on it then figure out whether you agree
or disagree with it you know um that's
that's
that might be helpful oh here's a good
question watergate 2.0
is john locke essential to understanding
human barkley lock is quite boring
um lock is dry i wouldn't say lock is
boring
once you actually understand what lock
is doing it's very interesting stuff
but he is he is quite dry and and the
essay
is really quite a slog
um is it essential
i mean you could understand hume
and barkley without reading lock i think
but you would be missing some stuff
in the process and lock is also
important for understanding
a lot of other thinkers as well uh
jonathan edwards is a great example the
you know one of the earliest american
philosophers
um in the reform tradition he's he's
essentially working off a block
it helps to understand locke as well
in order to be able to make sense out of
uh what's happening
in idealism and i don't just mean german
idealism i'm also thinking about
you know like coleridge um who's
bringing these this german idealistic
thought into english stuff who's usually
usually using lock as kind of like a a
foil
lock had a lot of importance so i think
i think it's good to read him
all right um dark storm
why would one strive to be happy over
being miserable why would the former be
better than the latter i mean that's one
of those no-brainers
um if you think that it's better to be
miserable go ahead and be miserable
uh most humans think it's better to be
happy
it's kind of a starting point an axiom
you could say it doesn't have to be
doesn't have to be proved um
ryan romandia what's your take on
william james i really like james
i i i enjoy him quite a bit as a matter
of fact if i if i was going to be a
pragmatist
it'd be james and royce who i'd be
reading
um not dewey because man i read enough
dewey when i was in grad school you know
dewey was sort of the hero of southern
illinois they had the dewey center there
i actually worked there for a semester
um but james is a lot of fun and james
will explore
all the sort of dark corners of things
he really is committed to radical
empiricism which means that
uh the empiricist didn't go far enough
and pierce this being you know locke
barkley hume
uh reed and others as well and
you know what we have to do is indeed go
further and and take the experiences
that are being offered to us the full
range of experience
as possibilities i'll i'll mention
somebody else to who's connected with
with james who i particularly like
george santayana as well
um so they're they're they're good to
check out
uh mj park if you watch the good place
show to be honest it's more
it's because of the tv show got me in to
read more philosophy books well if it
got you into philosophy that's good
the episodes that i've seen and the
references to it that i've seen i've not
been impressed by um
i think it's sort of like what somebody
who's got a smattering of philosophy
and good access to wikipedia put
together rather than somebody who
really likes philosophy i i watched like
the first
couple episodes and i was prepared to
really like it because i really like to
dance and
and i was like this is garbage i i'm not
watching any more of this and then
people
referenced it here and there
[Music]
but you know the stuff that they were
saying was all kind of so
surface level i mean it's good that it
made good that they talked about
philosophy a bit but
it could have been done better i think
uh
all right let's see what we've got here
valdrum andy o'leary what do you have to
say about modern analytic philosophy
putnam chomsky quine et cetera
i don't have anything to say about it
you know i don't i don't do it
and uh i i'm you know quinn is
interesting to read i used to read him a
long time ago
i never took chomsky that really that
seriously and his linguistic stuff
um i always found it kind of far-fetched
um
mj park sorry about the dog yeah
mika was was really a good dog
and you know my wife and i have been
talking pretty much
daily about things that we realized
about her
missed about her and it was a tough
decision
um you know especially for my wife
because she
she raised amica from a puppy who was
picked out
from the other puppies in her litter
by the other dog that my wife had also
fostered from a puppy
uh all of them were rescues and so yeah
it was it was tough and then
you know walking around here in
milwaukee when we first moved here in
2015
i the dogs were both like in really good
shape
and i would take them and we would walk
for miles
in this this whole area and so
this has been going on for for quite a
while for me as i'm walking places i
remember you know how much
how much they enjoyed this or you know
that we did this here
and and then i miss them because uh
they made a big impression on my life
uh brandel calrissian any favorite
eastern philosophers
um i don't know that i have any i mean i
don't know that i have favorites when it
comes to philosophers in general
um it's been a long time since i've i've
taught any of that stuff but i did enjoy
reading quite a bit of stuff in chinese
philosophy
and um and what you what you've got
there largely other than like the sort
of outlying moes tradition
um is essentially confucianism taoist
and buddhist stuff until we get into the
modern era
and you know i enjoyed reading it but i
can't say that i have anybody who's
really a favorite
for me um
[Music]
bhf hegelian cinema do i know of any
time
no i don't i don't think about hegelian
cinema
um kushal math can i do a ba in
philosophy even though it's the case
that i have not passed high school yeah
you just get a
ged a general equivalence diploma and
then
you can go to college and do philosophy
sure
there's nothing absolutely preventing
you from doing that
um let's see here
it's been years since i've tuned in i
think the last time i was here was when
google decided to remove the character
limit on comments
which i found exciting at the time good
to catch you live good good to have you
back here um muhammad
amin hadash what is the relation between
theory and post theory
i don't know i don't know what those
those
mean that could mean a million different
things so
all right let's scroll down and find
somebody i haven't answered before
um marcus is it fair to criticize kant
by asking how does he know that everyone
has these categories of the
understanding and everyone poses these
categories on the world
no actually it's not um because he
provides you
with you know some justifications for
that in his work
i mean you can take issue with the
justifications and say ah this isn't
sufficient but
but no that's sort of like a beginner
going to
you know a great strategist and saying
well why did you why did you do this
one thing and they'd be like read the
the plans
there they are you know um so no i i
wouldn't say that's it's that's a fair
criticism
um let's see
chernobyl best works of fiction so i
actually just did a
a talk with a friend of mine last night
about three books that that really
influenced me
um and one was
by ursula kayla green it's not actually
her best work but it had a big influence
on me as a kid
called the beginning place um if i was
gonna pick a work by ursula k le guin
that i would i would include
is like the best work it probably would
be
um
[Music]
the lathe of heaven or
[Music]
i don't know and if i could have like
the rokinon world
series that would be in there as well
because you've got that great middle
book um
or the you know the left-handed darkness
philip k dick's books are really great
um i talked
last night about scanner darkly but flow
my tears the policeman said is
is amazing too and so um
man in the high castle and so many other
works that he's he's written ubik
you know um of course dostoevsky is well
worth
reading um and we could go on and on
with with that
all right um
paul musso the virus has me
thinking about non-academic careers
which can use my philosophical skills
what's your sense of the demand for the
skills i learned in grad school out in
the real world
i don't know what skills you learned in
grad school because i don't know what
grad school you went to or
what you what you were learning there i
imagine that
being able to research if you you know
if you hopefully you did some
really deep solid research
and not just on you know very narrow
academic topics but
more broadly that can be a very valuable
skill
being able to communicate effectively
you know
that's often taken for granted one of
the things that philosophers
when they're trained well tend to be
very good at is making distinctions
but you've got to be able to make
distinctions at the right time at the
right place
for the right reason sort of virtue
ethics approach to that um
you know those those are the things that
come to mind right off the bat
being able to follow thoughts through
and lay out what you know
consequences are likely to be that's
also quite useful
but you gotta be able to communicate
with ordinary people that is
absolutely essential um and resist the
temptation of like turning things into
a a philosophical problem because most
people are not
interested in getting to the very bottom
depth of
of things so all right
um let's see what else we got here
uh just
skipped a little bit um
wow
let's see a lot of questions here
and we're getting kind of short on time
and i've got another thing to do
uh later on today um
lprmc would love to hear your take on
mock sterners the unique in its property
stringer is an interesting guy
um kind of a dead end i think as far as
hegelianism and
where it was going um you know
the the the structure of
the unique in its property the ego on
its own is very hegelian
he loves trees and stuff like that
and it's interesting stuff i mean you
can definitely see him as an
existentialist in a certain way
um it's fun to read him
i'll say that and i do teach him
occasionally
when i'm teaching ethics classes and
talking about egoism
so all right um
let's find somebody else who i haven't
answered a question for
oh here's a good question mj park do you
think it's a good idea to watch a video
explaining philosophy book before
reading it
as i usually do that uh no i think it's
a good idea to read the
read the book first and then go to video
resources or other resources
and then come back to it um you know
videos are not supposed to be a
substitute for actually
doing the work of putting that stuff
into your brain
and and uh working through it you know
all right um
let's see
nathan packard is it fair to interpret
nietzsche as a sort of dynamist that was
the impression of nature i got after
reading to lose his book on him
depends on what you mean by dynamist um
so you know and delisa's book on
nietzsche is a good
book and it does get at some
important aspects of nietzsche um
i actually do like to lose history
philosophy stuff quite a bit
but it's always good to keep in mind
that whenever you're reading to lose on
somebody you're getting more to lose
then you're getting that somebody
so i wouldn't read it as like sort of a
faithful uh interpretation of nietzsche
um that said there there are there i
don't think there's anybody who's like a
faithful interpretation of nietzsche
as such it's always emphasizing one
thing more
than another
and you know the loser's nature book is
quite good
all right um
[Music]
do you scroll down and see what i can
answer in the five minutes that we have
left uh go priest are you going ever
going to cover
jill de luz yeah eventually i mean if
you want me to do it sooner than later
everybody knows i do commission videos
so
if you really got the hankering for
something you can you know
you can have me change my schedule and
move things up in it but there's so many
other
so many other philosophers who i teach
more often and i think
need to be addressed
all right um mr big weakness why do you
think the hellenistic schools died out
during the medieval period um
i don't think they died out during the
medieval period i think they largely
died out before them
the medieval period and as antiquity was
drawing to a close
and if we're talking about let's let's
specify
here i'm talking about the west right
i'm not just talking about
byzantium where they um they were
preserved and did continue on or the
islamic world where
you know certainly aristotelianism and
platonism uh
managed to go on
in in large part um
the texts that did survive like say from
the stoics
or you know the discussions in cicero
were preserved by
monks who did in fact
draw upon them and seneca was a big
favorite
so it's it's less correct to say that
they died out
more to say that what was useful in them
got assimilated just like in in you know
neoplatonus philosophy
you see you know neoplatonus philosophy
isn't just let's
let's reinterpret plato it's well we got
plato and he's got the
top stuff right but let's see what we
can draw from the stoics and the
aristotelians and whoever else
um and you know
if you look at early medieval philosophy
you're going to see discussions of
the the various philosophical schools
they it just seems like they were
they they weren't really felt as viable
options on their own in a purist sort of
way you know they're adapting to
new problems and questions and
experiences
so that's probably it all right
bruno van de castiel i seem to have
trouble
diving into philosophy books recently
any tips to keep one focused and not
distracted by life phone
the phone is easier than life right
because the phone you can put down
um i don't know i i think there are
there are times
like this this crisis that we're in
right now it's a little bit harder i
suppose to
focus on um
some things and maybe maybe you don't
have to focus on philosophy right now
maybe you can focus on things that are
adjacent to philosophy
and that's fine you know there's nothing
that says that you have to do
this right now and this right now this
right now we can always
um you know you can always come back to
stuff
um and you know
in the case of bruno i know that he has
kids as well and kids can often
be major distractors they're wonderful
when
you know you're going through seeing
them develop
and life experiences and all that but
they can also
make it quite difficult to get things
done um
so all right let me see if i can find
one other
good question to go out on
all right
all right um
a lot of questions here
[Music]
oh here's a here's an interesting one
um and i'm not gonna be able to actually
give like a full answer to this but
how to know if i'm good at philosophy or
not so
i don't think that anybody's like good
at philosophy in the way that people are
like good at football
or good at um playing an instrument
or even good at math i think that
we can ask ourselves do i have an
aptitude for doing philosophy and in
most cases the answer will be yes
but we may not be adaptable to
everything i mean
there are there are areas of philosophy
that i'm never gonna
get into and really explore um
and that's okay and it's okay for you to
do that as well
i i think a more important question is
how do i effectively make progress
in philosophy and how can i tell if i'm
doing that and so
one way to think about that would be
to set up you might call them
you know movable benchmarks for yourself
what can you actually remember of the
philosophers who you've studied can you
can you take their thought and apply it
to to things in your life or to perhaps
events in history or
things that you think are important and
when you find yourself inevitably saying
oh crap i can't do it
well that's not a sign that you should
get discouraged and say oh i'm just no
good at this
that's a sign that you want to go back
and hit the books i mean i
myself you know i've been studying some
of these thinkers for 30 years
and i still have to go back and say oh
crap what was
what was plato's point that he was
making in this dialogue
here um you know what was going on
and you know if i find the time to do
that then then that's good
and so you'll have to do things like
that along the way as well and that's
just the way it works
in in philosophy and in the humanities
in general with literature with
you know religious studies with history
with
psychology now we're getting social
sciences
so it's less about being good at
something
and more about thinking well how do i
how do i gauge whether i'm
actually whether i've made progress or
whether i'm still making progress
and so ultimately these all end up being
sort of pragmatic
tests there's no one single
answer to these these sorts of things so
that's a good question to
go out on um obviously i didn't get to
everybody's questions i never
i never managed to do that but i got to
quite a few of them
and hopefully i'll see some of you in
some of our other
online events this month we've got quite
a few
going on so wherever you are in the
world
uh have a good morning afternoon
evening whatever time it is by you